Northbound southbound eastbound
westbound alternates all right the
reason why there are so many delays
there's a lot of folks coming out for
the Consumer Electronics Show Nate
Tanenbaum has a preview and a look at
some of the highlights with Dr Frank
the next product this is by free to move
it's by stellanis okay and free to move
basically what's interesting about the
the product is it's an Innovative new
service providing a global Mobility Hub
so let's say you want to buy an EV but
you're not sure right right okay so
Freedom move will allow you to basically
schedule that vehicle for a day a week
or a month how about that oh okay so
then you derive it right and you decide
exactly you know what this is great you
have an opportunity to look at these and
that's important so they're going to be
available shortly in Washington DC and
Denver they're opening soon in Dallas
but they plan for 200 more hubs around
the world they're very big in in Europe
now I got to tell you something about
this last product we're talking about
flash drives right you and I remember
the Consumer Electronics Show when there
was a 64 megabyte flash drive and it was
like Revolution wow You'll never have
anything that will hold more than 64
megabytes and this is the next gen
fastest USB 3.2 Drive available it's by
Kingston it comes in type c and type a
right which is important right rugged
case speed is up to 100 or to a thousand
megabytes read speeds and so forth and
they have it up to one terabyte so you
can have your entire data in your pocket
and unbelievable I mean are you kidding
a terabyte on a flash drive yeah
that's crazy yeah but no other flash
drive in the market is as fast as this
is by Kingston okay that's very
important look at the price yeah it's
starting in 43 bucks crazy isn't it but
it's so good to see you man Dr Frank
viciado the gadget guy thanks for having
me buddy
we'll have more on some of the Cool Tech
finds that are featured at CES coming up
on our website at 8newsnow.com good to
see Dr Frank again it's been too long
coming up a new warning from